hey I was going brothers money today
we're gonna do business everything it's
been so long since we did one of these
episodes and before we even begin I have
to be appropriately dressed great now
let's begin read a fanfiction and then
Dan and Phil finally fugged there's
everything try fitting yourself into a
washing machine or a fridge laughs in a
way you've never laughed before lick
Edgar no no no no no no you can't leave
back everything lick Maya Maya Maya oh
sorry there's everything like my [ __ ]
there's everything try to be seductive
with your eyes closed
there's everything show us a hidden
talent of yours I can lick my nose mmm
how you doing ladies
fun fact I did that for Marzia when we
recently met and I think that's one of
the reason why she started liking me I
don't get it either [ __ ] there's
everything make up a dance for the Bros
[Music]
dancers everything do yoga with Edgar
again
[Music]
we got new backpacks there pretty cool
do parkour in one area our inflatable
outfits yeah
[Music]
he's pooping pictures everything become
a japanese schoolgirl that's racist yes
there's everything sing a serious song
for Edgar why did you have to
[Music]
Shh thank you boosters everything do a
jump-scare for the viewers that's stupid
mm aw you got scared by boobs
everything cry in the shower is
everything all right breast that was
pizzas everything I hope you enjoyed it
if you did leave a like for every like
you get Yoko's boobs in your face hope
you enjoyed this video bros i'm sorry i
haven't done a lot of pizzas everything
the truth is I I had a panic attack when
I did one about a year ago it was my own
fault I just did so many crazy things at
once I hadn't eaten anything and my body
just stopped and it was really scary
it's not a big deal but ever since that
I just haven't felt like making one
because I'm like yeah thanks your answer
on that thank you guys for watching and
i'll see in the next one as always stay
awesome brush
[Music]